así
en el vídeo anterior vimos como las
lentes pueden enfocar los rayos de luz
paralelos hacia un punto del plano de la
imagen y dar como resultado una imagen
nítida esto significa que si el plano de
la imagen está a la distancia focal de
nuestra lente entonces los objetos que
están muy lejos aparecerán nítidos por
ejemplo imagina una escena en la cual
alegría se encuentra a un kilómetro y
medio de la cámara así si vemos la
escena del lado obtenemos esto observa
que los rayos de luz que rebotan en la
alegría y entran en la cámara son casi
paralelos si colocamos nuestro plano de
la imagen a la distancia focal de la
lente alegría estará bien enfocada pero
qué ocurre si tratamos de tomar una
imagen de los objetos cercanos de la
escena imagina que movemos la cámara
para que alegría esté a unos cuantos
metros
ahora escoge cualquier punto sobre
alegría y mira los rayos de luz que se
dirigen a ese punto hacia la lente de la
cámara
observa que estos rayos de luz no son
paralelos sino que se abren en abanico
como tocan la lente en ángulo terminan
en un punto que está un poco atrás del
plano de la imagen allí donde los rayos
de luz tocan en el plano de la imagen se
desparraman en círculos grandes y no en
puntitos nítidos esto da como resultado
una imagen de alegría que está
desenfocada para ver este efecto con
claridad mira esta imagen de luces
desenfocadas estos círculos borrosos se
conocen como círculos de confusión son
el resultado de rayos de luz que no se
han enfocado en un punto del plano de la
imagen cuando una imagen está enfocada
los círculos de confusión son tan
pequeños que aparecen como puntos en
nuestra imagen podemos enfocar alegría
moviendo el plano de la imagen un poco
hacia atrás así a esta distancia alegría
estar enfocada y nítida recuerda que con
la cámara estenopeica el tamaño del
estenopo o apertura determinaba lo
borroso o nítido de toda la imagen
con una pequeña apertura toda la escena
estaba enfocada pero ahora con una lente
en medio solo una parte de nuestra
escena estará enfocada todo lo que se
encuentre fuera de esta área de enfoque
que está muy cerca o muy lejos aparecerá
desenfocado esto se conoce como
profundidad de campo los cineastas
controlan la profundidad de campo con su
selección de lente y de apertura o
número f pongamos un ejemplo con muchas
alegrías a distancias diferentes de
nuestra cámara si la apertura es muy
pequeña será como un número f grande la
profundidad de campo será mayor y la
transición entre nítido y borroso será
muy gradual
para ver esto empecemos con una imagen
que esté enfocada y nítida a medida que
la muevo más lejos la zona borrosa no
cambia mucho esta es una gran
profundidad de campo así que más de una
de nuestras alegrías estará bien
enfocada ahora aumentemos el tamaño de
la apertura es decir con un número f
menor
y empecemos de nuevo con nuestra modelo
enfocada si la alejamos incluso un poco
la zona borrosa crece muy rápido esto se
llama poca profundidad de campo así que
con una apertura pequeña o un número f
grande hay mucha profundidad de campo
toda la escena está bien enfocada con
una apertura más grande o un número f
más pequeño hay poca profundidad de
campo sólo una pequeña parte de nuestra
escena está bien enfocada en el
ejercicio siguiente tendrás oportunidad
de explorar como en la apertura y el
tipo de lente afectan la profundidad de
campo